[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here okay so i'm in
the last stages of my macbook pro review
a lot of you been asking where it is i'm
not rushing it it is not early so sorry
about that but uh my final bits of
testing include editing a full mkbhd
video shot in red code raw on the
16-inch m1 max macbook pro
that's this video so if you're seeing
this then that means at some point i got
through that whole process so hopefully
that went well if it didn't go well then
check my twitter because that's probably
where i was complaining about how things
went uh either way
that's next up until then these
are the most popular headphones on earth
these are airpods so the newest update
you're looking at here is airpods 3.
they were a quieter announcement at last
month's apple event but they're 179
and honestly the story with these is
well there's quite a bit of new stuff
but also the competitive landscape for
earbuds has been heating up for years
and there have never been more high
quality alternatives to airpods than
there are right now so the new airpods 3
design basically looks just like a set
of airpods pro but without the silicon
tips like someone chopped them off it's
a the one size fits all hard tip from
the air pods of the past and this is
simultaneously its biggest advantage
and its biggest downside for people like
me see the shape
is just slightly adjusted from previous
hard-tipped airpods you can see it's
more of a wedge shape where it goes into
your ear it's a slightly bigger opening
at the end and it's a bit more of a
larger bulb but basically the idea is
that it's pretty close to the common ear
and it just pops in and sits there no
problem
at least it's supposed to for most
people but for me again it's not the
best fit the left one happens to stay in
pretty well but then the right ones
constantly feeling like it's slowly
sliding out of my ear and eventually it
just falls out if i'm not constantly
adjusting it so it's pretty annoying
clearly not for me and for that reason i
still prefer silicon tips instead of
hard plastic i am super jealous of all
you people who just grab air pods and
just put them in your ears and they just
stay forever and just run around um i'm
not one of those people oh well but i
did test these for a little bit and
there are some other new things aside
from just the new design so there's the
controls on the stem now on both sides
like airpods pro you pretty quickly get
used to squeezing it to play and pause
you can double tap to go to the next
song etc there's no noise cancellation
in these but you can see the mesh cutout
on the back and around all the mics all
around this thing for adaptive eq it
passes through some of the sound from
the outside mainly to feel a bit more
open than some other earbuds they are
sweat and water resistant now so if you
want to work out in them you might have
already done it but they'll officially
be fine now and also if you walk around
in the rain no problem and there's also
a new horizontal case looks just like
the airpods pro case but it's a little
bit smaller and for the first time the
case is also officially ipx4 water
resistant so like they might have
survived water in the past but it's
officially official now still lightning
at the bottom unfortunately but this new
case is now improved it'll still do
wireless charging but it's also now
magsafe compatible which just means
it'll snap onto the iphone's magsafe
charging puck and it holds pretty well
there too this magsafe wireless charging
case isn't unique to airpods 3 though by
the way they quietly also updated the
airpods pro case to also snap onto the
magnets but they didn't also update it
for water resistance so
small difference what would have been
even cooler is if you could trickle
charge them via the qi charging on the
back of the iphone since they're both qi
charging it would have been the sickest
like little ecosystem plug they could
have called it reverse mag safe charging
but there they don't talk to each other
like that it needs some extra hardware
to reverse wireless charge iphones don't
have that so that's not a real feature
in this product like it is with some
other phones and their earbuds now if
you decide to grab the sexiest case on
earth the dbrand icons case or pretty
much any other airpods case no magnetic
snapping but yes wireless charging does
still work if you're wondering i'll have
a link below to this case if you want to
protect your headphones and make sure
you get an airpods 3k specifically
because like i said airpods pro cases
are slightly different dimensions they
won't quite fit
but really the most interesting change
to airpods
honestly is the sound
they have a and i can't believe i'm
saying this a perfectly respectable
sound now so it's legitimately very
improved i've trashed on airpods in the
past as you guys have probably
remembered for how weak they sound how
tiny they've been
these airpods when they're sat right in
your ears have much more body and bass
frequencies now and they get plenty loud
as always
and they really do sound pretty solid
now the caveat is one there is no eq
built in like a lot of other headphones
have and two
these were meant to still be good
basic everyday headphones and so apple
has tuned them as such meaning they've
got to be usable for phone calls and
podcasts which have a lot of high focus
on vocal frequencies but also
music listening in a variety of genres
and then also movie watching and
everything in between but one feature
that sort of gets highlighted at least
every time apple talks about these
headphones is spatial audio now i don't
typically use spatial audio very much
but
every time i try these i give them
another shot and basically there are two
types of spatial audio experiences so
one is if you're just listening to music
or watching a video and you can just
force it on with the ios settings
and the head tracking turns on and for
most mixes it basically sounds like
you're suddenly in a small room with a
set of speakers in front of you and as
you turn your head from left to right
those speakers will sound like they
continue to stay in front of you but
then two there's a very small number of
really well done mixes in dolby atmos
and you can find some on apple music
they actually do a great job of
separating
the instruments and the channels and
sort of spreading them out around you
and this whole symphony with a decent
sound stage and the airpods do a good
job of letting you kind of place the
instruments and vocals around you in
space around your head but i find that
to be a pretty rare experience if you
get to listen to these listen to uh
blessings by big sean that's one really
good example
but again these types of tracks are few
and far between but ultimately the sound
for me
comes down to the hard tipped plastic
they do sound much much better but
unfortunately i have one of the cursed
ears that doesn't work with hard-tipped
earbuds so i would take silicon tipped
earbuds every single time some people
are the total other way around so
there's a lot of people comparing
airpods pro
with airpods 3. i would personally pay
the extra money for airpods pro also
right now if you check on amazon airpods
pro have been like 190 bucks for a while
and this is the new version too with the
updated case so it's like 10 extra
dollars to get the noise cancellation
and the silicon tips i'm picking that
every single time but
for some people who don't care about
that type of thing this is what they'll
pick but that's really the summary for
these headphones they don't really do
any one thing
amazingly meaning they'll get beat in
certain single categories but they do
everything you'd want headphones to do
daily very well they have a slightly
longer but totally reasonable six hour
battery life they have an all-around
good tune that's not adjustable they
have a small case that wireless charges
and they fit great in the iphone's
ecosystem they instantly pair with the
rest of your icloud devices and
seamlessly switch between them and they
have better find my ability now so if
you lose the case
which i don't know how many people lose
just the case but if you do you can use
find my to track that down it's not
nearly as super precise as air tags but
it's very convenient to get a
notification on your iphone if you start
to leave somewhere and you realize you
left your airpods behind but look at the
whole rest of the landscape it's way
more diverse and interesting now beats
fit pro just came out today these have
the best in-ear fit of any earbud i've
ever worn wing tip
for the win they're amazing for working
out they have noise cancellation
but they have a kind of a still clunky
case that also doesn't have wireless
charging or check these these are the
sony
wf-1000xm4 these also blow the airpods
out of the water in terms of sound
quality but if you've ever worn these
i mean
they're much bigger and don't really sit
in the ear as comfortably and you
wouldn't work out in these and they're
250 dollars so they're in a different
price category there's also the nothing
earbuds that i reviewed which have a
better battery life but also a pretty
big case that does wireless charge and
it's a more interesting distinctive
design especially with the buzz that i
really like
but they don't fit as well in the ios
ecosystem and then there's also
samsung's buds too which have a lot of
the same stuff and wireless charging but
you get the idea there's a lot out there
so air pods are meant to sit
right in the middle of the road like
that's they don't do any of the things
amazingly in any one category but they
do everything pretty well and that's
what makes them so easy to recommend
it's also they came out right before the
holiday season like they know i i'm
probably gonna end up getting these as a
gift for some people
they're incredibly popular for that
exact reason but here's a fun fact
airpods
if you just cut off airpods from apple
and just made it its own separate
company airpods inc
that company would be worth about 175
billion dollars
that's from an estimate from back in
2019 just looking at how many they're
selling approaching 100 million units
tons of revenue obviously but
can you imagine
just a headphone company by itself with
only like three models
being worth 175
billion dollars like just for some
context logitech which makes lots of
headphones but also plenty of other
accessories is worth 14 billion dollars
sony which makes headphones but a ton of
other stuff they make movies they make
the playstation they make phones and
cameras sony's worth like 150 billion
dollars tops right now so
that's that's not to say these
headphones are amazing but that's to say
they are probably the best lure to bring
people into the iphone ecosystem
and they're all around extremely
convenient they're the easy choice so
there you have it thanks for watching
hopefully the macbook pro isn't
exploding exporting this video catch you
guys soon with that review but until the
next one it's techvember
that doesn't roll off the tongue as well
see you guys next video
peace